hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es von mir ein Rezept für
Cupcakes aber ich zeige euch gleich drei
Versionen wie ihr die Cupcakes richtig
hübsch dekorieren könnt
[Musik]
fertig also hier sind erstmal die
Zutaten für den Cupcake an sich das ist
so ein Vanille Rezept ein Basic lege ich
euch auch gerne als Basic Rezept an
damit ihr zu jeder Jahreszeit Cupcakes
zubereiten könnt egal was ihr daraus
machen wollt ihr braucht dafür nämlich
einfach nur zwei Eier etwas
Vanilleextrakt jeweils 150 g Buttermilch
und Sonnenblumenöl 150g Zucker etwas
Salz und 200 g Mehl plus Backpulver oder
nimmt einfach direkt mein backmehl da
ist nämlich Backpulver in der perfekten
Dosierung schon mit dabei und am besten
nehmt ihr euch jetzt zwei Schüsseln ihr
braucht auch kein Handrührgerät keine
Küchenmaschine das geht alles mit dem
Schneebesen
gibt dir zuerst einmal die trockenen
Zutaten in eine Schüssel
und in die zweite Schüssel hier gibt es
jetzt einfach die flüssigen Zutaten
und natürlich die wichtigste Zutat
Tag
statt Buttermilch könnt ihr auch
jederzeit Milch verwenden dann aber
gerne einen Schuss Zitronensaft
dazugeben ihr könnt auch Sprudelwasser
nehmen ihr könnt auch was mit Geschmack
nehmen so könnte nämlich den Geschmack
eurer Cupcakes einfach individualisieren
es kommen hier die trockenen Zutaten
rein und werden nur noch ganz kurz
eingerührt und so habt ihr wirklich in
Sekundenschnelle den perfekten Cupcakes
Teig und zum Portionieren nehme ich
jetzt am liebsten meinen Eisportionierer
dann sind die Cupcakes nämlich gleich
groß und man macht eben auch nichts
schmutzig
jetzt habe ich wahrscheinlich zu laut
gesagt bestimmt voll nein werde ich
nicht
für diese Muffinform nehme ich immer den
Eisportionierer in der Größe 11 der
passt immer perfekt dann ist die Form zu
dreiviertel gefüllt und ist nicht
überfüllt
perfekt und so kommen sie schon in den
vorgeheizten Backofen und werden für
etwa 20 bis 25 Minuten gebacken in der
Zwischenzeit kümmere ich mich schon mal
um die erdbeerfüllung
[Musik]
dafür nehme ich 600 Gramm Erdbeeren darf
ich das Grün bereits entfernt 100 g
Zucker etwas Vanilleextrakt Zitronensaft
und 5g Agar
da jetzt gerade Erdbeerzeit ist nämlich
natürlich frische Erdbeeren ansonsten
nehme ich aber auch gerne tiefgefrorene
Erdbeeren denn die sind auch richtig
schön aromatisch weil sie eben
erntefrisch eingefroren werden und weil
sie verkocht werden ist es dann auch
egal ob da zu viel Wasser drin ist oder
nicht deswegen könnte jetzt hier die
Erdbeeren entweder klein schneiden und
in den Topf geben ich spare mir das
kleinen schneiden ich nämlich gleich den
Rocker
wir kommen jetzt einfach die restlichen
Zutaten dazu
[Musik]
und damit ein bisschen eindeckt auch
Agar und jetzt einfach schön zerstampfen
dann jetzt kurz aufkochen lassen und
dann sollte die Masse 2 Minuten lang
sprudeln kochen damit das auch wirken
kann und das sorgt jetzt auch gleich
dafür dass das Wasser in den Erdbeeren
so ein bisschen verdunstet und ich
einfach mehr Erdbeergeschmack habe ohne
dass ich später die Creme einfach noch
sehr binden muss weil ich später dann
noch Quark und Sahne dazu gebe und
Erdbeeren an sich einfach zu flüssig
sind wenn man so das Erdbeere roh mit
dazu gibt deswegen einkochen lassen
damit das Wasser wegkommt
[Musik]
das Erdbeerpüree habe ich nach dem
kochen abkühlen lassen und zwar habe ich
dafür einfach in zwei Teller verteilt
schön abkühlen lassen in Kühlschrank
gestellt und jetzt hat es eine
dickflüssige Konsistenz einen Teil davon
werde ich in die Cupcakes reinfüllen und
einen Teil davon werde ich jetzt für die
App bei Creme verwenden und dafür
benutze ich außerdem 200 Gramm
Frischkäse 30 g Puderzucker 250 g
Magerquark 200 g Erdbeerpüree 200g Sahne
und etwas Sahne zum steif schlagen
wundert euch nicht die Schlüssel war
noch in der Spülmaschine und war noch
warm deswegen habe ich kurz ein Eisberg
drunter damit sie kalt ist sonst geht
meine Creme kaputt also ihr nehmt jetzt
erstmal den Frischkäse statt Frischkäse
könnt ihr auch gerne noch Quark benutzen
falls ihr den nicht so gerne mögt aber
ich muss sagen ich bin Frischkäse in
Cremes wirklich wunderbar
Puderzucker dazu Quark dazu
und alles kurz verrühren
jetzt die Sahne langsam zugeben und mit
seiner partycreme steif schlagen
und wenn die Creme fest ist dann einfach
kurz in den Kühlschrank stellen
auf die einen Cupcakes kommen jetzt noch
schokoerdbeeren drauf dafür nehme ich
jetzt einfach nur weiße Kuvertüre ihr
könnt natürlich auch Zartbitter Robi
oder Vollmilchkuvertüre verwenden ihr
gebt zwei Drittel davon über ein warmes
Wasserbad und lasst es schmelzen nimmt
dann die flüssige Schokolade herunter
und rührt das restliche Drittel ein so
hat die Schokolade die perfekte
weiterverarbeitungstemperatur hat einen
schönen Glanz und wird auch schön fest
jetzt werden die Erdbeeren hier hinein
getunkt falls der Erdbeer nicht mehr
vorhanden ist könnt ihr einfach einen
Zahnstocher hinten reinpieksen und die
Erdbeere schön zur Hälfte hinein tunken
ansonsten geht's natürlich auch ohne und
jetzt gibt's noch eine kleine Trick denn
ich würde gerne so kleine Streifen auf
die Erdbeeren drauf drüben lassen und es
geht nicht wenn die Kuvertüre so perfekt
ist wie hier das heißt ihr gibt einfach
einen Teil davon in ein Schälchen
verrührt mit ganz ganz ganz wenig warmem
Wasser dann wird die so ein bisschen
fester und zerläuft nicht mehr so und
damit könnt ihr dann am Ende schreiben
oder auch feine Linien ziehen das reicht
schon
die Cupcakes sind jetzt abgekühlt und
jetzt nehmt ihr am besten einen
apfelentkerne und Stechen in der Mitte
einfach eine Vertiefung rein ihr könnt
das ganze auch gerne mit einem
Ausstecher machen oder mit einem Messer
einschneiden und dann mit dem Löffel
ausfüllen denn da kommt gleich das
abgekühlte etwas Fruchtpüree rein
und damit es einfach geht habe ich es
hier schon mal in der Dosierflasche
eingefüllt
man kommt das hier direkt in die
Cupcakes rein
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt Version 1 dafür nehme
ich hier eine Spritztülle das ist hier
die große rosettentöne und ich nehme
jetzt hier vier Cupcakes den
Spritzbeutel oben mal gut festhalten und
senkrecht halten und dann relativ flach
aufspritzen so dass in der Mitte eine
Öffnung entsteht für die erdbeerwürfel
[Musik]
Schrank und wir dekorieren Version
Nummer 2
und auf die zweite Version der Cupcakes
kommt jetzt eine etwas größere Erdbeere
Sahne drauf
[Musik]
und für die Version 3 habe ich die Creme
in den Spritzbeutel mit einer großen
lochhülle gefüllt damit kann man nämlich
auch ganz ganz tolle Sahnehäubchen
dann ein bisschen gefriergetrocknetes
himbeer- oder Erdbeerpulver drauf
bisschen Amaranth
und eine halbe Erdbeere
ich finde ja alle drei sind richtig
hübsch geworden die sind alle so so ganz
unterschiedlich oder was sagst du Alex
hallo hallo wir sind echt richtig
richtig schön was ist so dein Favorit
ich finde den richtig schön der sieht
auch sehr aufwendig aus
und mit den Streifen sieht schon sehr
edel aus aber die anderen zwei sind auch
sehr schön ich glaube mein Favorit ist
sogar der Mitte den finde ich auch
richtig schön der ist auch hübsch ach
die sind irgendwie also schmecken tun
sie alle gleich deswegen rechts und
probieren oder ja ich zeige euch mal
kurz den Querschnitt wow ach die sind
noch innen drin noch gefüllt
die sind
also Murat beißt er immer rein aber ich
bin dann nicht so Fan
die sind wirklich richtig schön aus ich
finde das sind auch also wenn jetzt so
die Hochzeitssaison kommt finde ich sind
es auch richtig hübsche Hochzeit
Cupcakes stimmt ohne gute Idee diese mit
der Erdbeere
und wenn man eine weiße Creme machen
würde kann man ja auch die Creme weiß
belassen und die erdbeerfüllung innen
rein dann sind die Außen nicht rosa
aber so geschmacklich finde ich das
schon also wenn wir jetzt sehen aber ist
bestimmt gut
richtig gut ja
auch richtig fruchtig die Füllung wow
also schmeckt richtig lecker Murat wird
jetzt sagen schmeckt wie Fruchtzwerge
das stimmt
immer wenn er findet das was gut
schmeckt dann sagt
schmeiß ich natürlich ja aber schmeckt
wirklich richtig gut und sieht auch mega
schön aus also ich finde auch also da
ich mich nicht entscheiden konnte habe
ich natürlich alle drei Rezepte für euch
angelegt und alle drei Deko Variationen
aber ihr könnt ja mal schreiben welche
Version euch am besten gefällt Version 1
mit den Erdbeer würfeln und Version 2
mit der Schokoladen Erdbeere oder
Version 3 mit der Lufthülle schreibt
gerne in die Kommentare ich bin mal
gespannt drauf und falls ihr noch mehr
Erdbeer Rezepte sehen wollt dann
schreibt auch gerne denn dann lasse ich
mir auf jeden Fall noch was einfallen
Erdbeer Rezepte also so lange gedauert
Klaus so viele Erdbeeren hat finde ich
können wir auch Erdbeere Rezepte
raushauen
keine Erdbeeren oder ja
die Rezepte findet ihr auch Sallys
blog.de und in meiner App probiert gerne
mal aus ich freue mich auf euer Feedback
und wir sehen uns wieder das nächste Mal
tschüss
[Musik]